Mao's investigation suggests that Russia
and other foreign countries have been
meddling in this country for some time
so raises an obvious question which is
business dismissed in the media but it's
a real one what would the last
administration they knew about this why
didn't they do anything about it and
where was the FBI Piers Morgan is the
host of good morning Britney he's editor
at large for Daily Mail comm and we're
happy to have him join us tonight
so piers you're obviously looking at
this from a foreign vantage and you
think of the FBI is this kind of storied
law enforcement organization that always
gets its man have you revised your take
on the FBI after over the last year
well I've revised it certainly in the
last week which i think has been one of
the worst ever weeks for the FBI and
it's 109 year history Chuck and I'll
tell you why two reasons one take the
Russia investigation Donald Trump is
president United States now and has been
for just over a year but there remains
zero evidence that says that he colluded
with anyone from Russia in any attempt
to fix a u.s. election that's just a
fact now Miller may have some secret
evidence but he hasn't produced it so
right now there is no evidence linking
Trump to any collusion so that then
prompts a question well okay but we now
know there was Russian meddling in the
u.s. election we don't know quite the
scale of it it may be as breeches said
reasonably small and not that
significant but there was meddling and
you would expect that but whose job was
it to deal with that middling to stop it
happening well that would be the
previous president Barack Obama who from
2014 when the meddling started it was
his job it was on his watch and he's got
seventeen intelligence agencies led by
the FBI and he is their responsibility
in my view to investigate and to stop
and to close down the kind of meddling
that we saw from these Russians and that
simply did not happen and so I would say
that if you combine that performance by
the FBI in terms of the Russian
investigation or lack of it that was
going on and then you look at what
happened with the mass shooting this
week in Florida where this is one of the
most spectacular ball drops that I've
ever seen from any intelligence agency
yes the FBI were warned twice once that
this guy had apparently posted on a blog
a commentary that he was going to be a
school shooter he is a very unusual name
the shooter
Nicholas Cruz with Nicolas Pelt in a
very unusual name the FBI were not able
to trace him and yet he had a background
check to purchase the ar-15 with which
he committed his crime they could have
found him in five minutes can't forward
four months to the start of January and
then we have a most extraordinary
situation where it turns out somebody
very close to Cruz the shooter phoned
the FBI tip line specifically designed
for cryptid tips about crime and
potential crime and said this guy is
dangerous he's heavily armed we think he
may be planning to shoot up a school
they gave them chapter and verse on this
blow and the FBI didn't even refer it to
its head office in Miami
it didn't even pursue this despite now
having two warnings that this guy might
be armed dangerous unstable mentally ill
and prepared to shoot a schooler now you
put those two things together Tucker and
I'm sorry this is a pretty appalling
performance by the FBI leading me to
conclude in my column today they'd be
better off calling the Federal Bureau of
incompetence well and you would add to
that and of course everything you said
is factually true and I think your
interpretation is right you add to that
the Las Vegas sheeting which low these
were the biggest in American history low
these months later we have no
understanding of why that happened and
there's a there's a trail of incompetent
decisions by law enforcement so here's
my question given all of that I think
your position is a reasonable one why is
it that people who say that are
denounced as unpatriotic by media
figures in this country why is it
unpatriotic talking sh in federal
agencies what is interesting isn't it I
mean I think that the partisan nature of
American politics is now so extreme and
it's on both sides to a large degree
bacilli the anti-trump hysteria in
particular means that people are not
able to see the wood for the trees I
come from another country I look at this
with a pretty clear open mind you know I
wrote 36 columns about Donald Trump for
the Daily Mail last year 18 of them were
supportive 18 were critical I'm a
reasonably impartial voice in this
debate and I would simply say to all
those who don't want any
of Barack Obama for what happened with
the Russian meddling or for the FBI with
the meddling or now the investigation of
this shooter take a good long look at
yourselves because if this has happened
with Donald Trump let's reverse it let's
say that you know Donald Trump had been
the president when all this meddling was
actually going on and we knew it was
going on there would be absolute outrage
that he hadn't stopped - yes and so I
think it's perfectly legitimate to look
at Barack Obama and say where were you
when this meddling was happening on your
watch and the answer is that he and the
FBI seemed far more exercised to be
investigating other technology in terms
of emails and Hillary Clinton and
servers and so on quite legitimately but
were they basically taking their eye off
the ball and not focusing on what is
probably for the American country far
more serious which is persistent Russian
meddling through new technology through
American companies like Facebook Twitter
derail and others using and abusing them
to try and influence and corrupt voting
patterns and voting thinking you can't
argue simultaneously that that was a big
deal and Obama is blameless for not
investigating I agree with that Piers
Morgan thank you good to see you tonight
I've Duncan